et syrie on va parler de brigitte macro
brigitte macron insulté faut-il répondre
aux attaques depuis plusieurs semaines
brigitte macron est la cible de
critiques sexiste de la part des
responsables politiques brésiliens ce
week-end sa fille a lancé sur twitter le
hashtag balances ton miso on vous a
résumé la situation et bernard montiel
va nous donner de ses nouvelles
c'est vrai que elle s'en prend plein la
gueule mine de rien c'est là c'est vrai
que ça devient ça devient fou que ça
prend des proportions incroyables
sophie bot si vous avez été l'objet de
cible sur instagram pouvez nous en
parler dans un instant regardez petit
récapitulatif la grosse polémique du
moment ce sont ces attaques répétées sur
le physique de la première dame de
france brigitte macron à l'origine un
commentaire déplacé du président
brésilien ball sonar ou sur facebook qui
a mis le feu aux poudres et a déclenché
la colère des manuels maquereau en plein
g7 le président brésilien n'a pas
beaucoup aimé les réflexions du
président macron sur l'amazonie nous ne
pouvons accepter qu'un président macron
lancent des attaques déplacées et
gratuite contre l'amazonie comme si
c'était une colonie et pour lui faire
payer ses déclarations l'homme a décidé
de répondre à sa manière en critiquant
le physique de la première dame sur
facebook vous comprenez pourquoi macron
persécute ball sonar au avant de
surenchérir en répondant à un internaute
avec un commentaire très cash n'humilie
pas le type mort de rire une attitude
qui a beaucoup irrité le président
français en plein g7 emmanuel macron a
décidé de répondre à bolton araud c'est
triste mais c'est triste d'abord pour
lui pour les brésiliens
mais s'il est le président du brésil
ball sonar ou ne semble pas être le
président de tous les brésiliens qui
massivement n'ont pas hésité à s'excuser
au nom de leur chef d'état
pour steris mme frêche du côté des
personnalités françaises nombreuses sont
celles qui ont fait part de leur
indignation ségolène royal carla bruni
et ce week-end sétif et nozière l'une
des filles de brigitte macron qui a
lancé sur les réseaux sociaux le hashtag
balances ton mise au régime
tout semble alors une question se pose
maintenant faut-il répondre aux attaques
alors vous le savez tout part d'un bras
de fer entre les manuels macron et le
président brésilien
au sujet des incendies en amazonie donc
le président a commenté le 25 août
dernier sur facebook une publication qui
se moquer du physique de brigitte macron
lundi soir c'est emmanuel macron en
personne qui est monté au créneau pour
défendre sa femme
on a les images regardez la vidéo de la
réponse du président ça n'arrive jamais
en france qu'un ministre de la
république insultes quelques dirigeants
que ce soit pour faire des insultes à
mon endroit et lui qu'il tienne des
propos extraordinairement et respectueux
à l'égard de mon épouse qu'est ce que je
peux vous dire c'est triste c'est triste
mais c'est triste d'abord pour lui et
pour les brésiliens
moi je pense que les femmes brésiliennes
ont sans doute honte de lire ça de leur
président je pense que les brésiliens
qui sont un grand peuple ont un peu
honte de voir ces comportements et ils
attendent quand on est président qu'on
se comporte bien à l'égard des autres et
comme j'ai beaucoup d'amitié de respect
pour le peuple brésilien
j'espère très rapidement qu'ils auront
un président qui se comporte à la
hauteur alors l'attitude du président
brésilien a choqué partout même au
brésil beaucoup de brésiliens ont tenu à
s'excuser auprès de la première dame
avec le hashtag des school pas brigitte
pardon brigitte indé school pas ça veut
dire pardon je fais un petit peu de
portugais en marge d'un déplacement
brigitte maquereau a tenu à remercier
les brésiliens qui l'avaient soutenu
regarder
[Musique]
en portugais
ça va pas être terrible je vais dire
quand même j'espère qu'ils entendront
c'est winter brigade a alors la semaine
dernière le président y a une nouvelle
fois ce responsable politique brésilien
le ministre brésilien des finances a
déclaré cette femme est vraiment moche
voilà c'est c'est incroyable
regardez on a le bon titre si on pouvait
le mettre voilà il ya une banderole deux
ans soutient brigitte mâcon qui a été
déployé sur le pont de périgueux
brigitte tu es belle et ce week-end
excédé par les attaques contre sa mère
typhaine dosière donc la fille brigitte
mâcon a lancé samedi le hashtag balances
ton miso dans une vidéo publiée sur
twitter
regardez la vidéo typhaine nous sommes
en 2019 et des responsables politiques
cible une femme publique sur son
physique
ça existe encore me direz vous et oui
mais réveillons-nous aragon la femme est
l'avenir de l'homme
alors tous ensemble et dès demain réagit
son investissement dans nos familles
dans nos entreprises et dans les urnes
pour que tous ensemble on balance
nouveau alors vous a posé la question
faut-il répondre aux attaques bernard
montiel
on sait que vous connaissez bien
brigitte macron il vous connaissez de
sifflet nozière très bien bien sûr elle
a trois enfants il ya tiphaine il ya
laurent c'est un garçon que sébastien
est ce que vous pensez qu'elle a bien
fait de faire cette vidéo il fait
nozière est ce que c'est parce que et
elle est triste pour sa maman
mais bien sûr bien sûr que ça peut
blesser la fille la finale vous insulter
votre maman on prend sa défense ça fait
normal d'autant plus que ces attaques
sont indignes d'un chef d'état ça il
faut quand même le souligner est
évidemment je crois que tout le monde
est d'accord pour dire que c'est honteux
c'est l'honneur d'une femme qui est
bafouée c'est l'honneur de toutes les
femmes qui est bafouée avec cette
histoire faut pas l'oublier c'est une
insulte incroyable d'un chef d'état d'un
si beau pays qui le brésil quand même
faut le dire on aime le brill regardez
il n'a pas eu que d'arguments quand même
pas
non mais c'est une contre attaque
politique par rapport parce que nous la
france on a reproché évidemment de
laisser brûler l'amazone y voit là et ça
parce que c'est le poumon ont quand même
du monde mais ça concerne l'humanité
c'est le monde entier c'est pas que le
brésil en caisse nous on est limitrophe
est ce que vous savez si brigitte macro
est touché par ces attaques se dit je
m'en fous totalement ce qu'on voit plein
de titres de presse qu'ils disent
brigitte macron blessé ou pas du tout
d'abord elle s'est pas exprimée sauf la
seule fois s'est exprimée vous l'avez
dit pour remercier le peuple brésilien
on ne peut pas parler au nom de la
première dame s'expriment toutes celles
selanne a envie je suis sûr qu'elle est
blessée jeu évidemment on dit tu es
moche sophie t'es moche ça blesse ça
blesse tout le monde ça baisse la
famille ça blesse les amis ça blesse
tout le monde l élégance de répondre
très gentiment avec le sourire parce que
c'est une femme bien et est le moins les
responsables on voit que c'est la femme
d'un chef d'état parce que
diplomatiquement elle a raison de ne pas
répondre et elle ne répondra pas elle ne
répondra jamais ça c'est clair ça je
peux vous l'affirmer répondra jamais
elle répondra jamais évidemment parce qu
elle est élégante et que
diplomatiquement on va pas s'attaquer
pour leur laissent eux la vulgarité
parce que ça c'est vulgaire ce qu'il a
fait quand même donc elle est nettement
au-dessus ans puis je vous dire il forme
avec emmanuel avec monsieur macron un
couple comme ils s'appellent sort il va
durer qu'emmanuel hérésie ou et ça fait
mouche
calme-toi échelonné texte je suis comme
ça je connais sa femme mais que ces
montures ça fait des années que le
couple macro affronter les regards
inquisiteurs des gens ça fait des années
dans l'habitude donc les insultes de ce
genre on y va quand qu'on a mais bon
vous semble s alors on fait pas de
politique ici et là on parle vraiment
joué le jeu de la femme c'est vrai que
mine de rien ça peut être blessant moi
je comprends sa fille tout est une vidéo
jean michel lamesch comprend des biens
dont sa fille quand sa mère est acquis
comme ça c'est tout à fait normal il
assuma qu'elle impose comme ça en
revanche rebalancer introduit mélenchon
miso ça on se rappelle de bâle a fait
beaucoup de dégâts
ce que les gens sont accusés les hommes
on prend plus les angles pour des
prédateurs maintenant c'est quand même
un peu puis assumer
on peut comprendre qu'au conscient pall
mall de votre mère nous avons eu à faire
quelque chose
la macro n'était pas au courant de la
démarche de série d'accords à ça c'est
une info hoyau pas était pas au courant
de la démarche cela mais avec moi c'est
comme quand à mr a insulté des personnes
qui parlait mal de moi c'est vrai que
c'est pas bien alors c'est un chemin
jusqu'à valence a attaqué dans ce débat
car la seule chose qu'elles ont déposé
des savates mon frère qui peut balancer
des hashtags mais oui dans messier mais
il est parce que c'est l'honneur des
femmes en général
et oui les beaux seins quand on est tous
à votre famille je peux comprendre que
témoin malam à mal à giuly ma mère à
jour ya un mec qui a mal parlé de moi là
elle a défoncé voilà mais bon c c c
c'est comme ça après je lui dis c'est
pas bien mais bon voilà une raison
alors moi je trouve que diplomatiquement
c'est très très faible de la part du
président brésilien en revanche ce que
je voudrais dire moi c'est que brigitte
macron elle a commis aucune erreur en
tant que première dame elle reste
toujours à sa place s'expriment jamais
elle ne veut pas faire d'ombré à son mac
on voit vous êtes sur le service public
vous non non mais c'est vrai je pense je
trouve que et en plus je trouve qu'elle
elle c'est un vrai modèle pour les
femmes d'une manière j'ai mis la voix
elle donc franchement c'est
insupportable c'est alors justement
alors sophie vous vous vous aviez posté
une photo sur un style photo de vous en
short et en tee shirt
un internaute a commenté alors que cette
magnifique en plus
regardez donc ces deux journées il y en
a tant d'autres il ya un internaute
camille c'est moche vos bras et vos
jambes et il a raison non arrêté non non
non mais en fait je si je poste des
photos c'est que justement je
j'assume de me montrer au naturel dans
la rue maquillage et du produit 50 soit
déjà blessé ou pas du tout jeu
honnêtement je lis rapidement les
commentaires j'ai céderait pour autant
que je peux on peut pas plaire à tout le
monde et il ya quand même quelques
personnes qui sont jalouses et gris bon
ça fait partie du ça fait partie du jeu
et ça fait partie des réseaux sociaux
oui mais moi si j'ai la démarche de
posté cette photo je me prends pas du
tout pour un sex symbol moi je j'assume
qui je suis va vous devriez oui la belle
alors mal en jetons biseau je suis comme
jean-michel je trouve que c'est en
dessous de la réponse de brigitte macron
c'est pas bien sandro et je comprends
qu'elle soit blessée
en revanche ce qui est
hier dans cette histoire c'est que quand
on dit des saloperies sur le physique
des gens mais c'était toujours avant en
privé éventuellement des journalistes le
répéter là c'est totalement décomplexée
et là vous le fils se trompe c'est que
quand elle vient en 2019 c'est
incroyable mais c'est surtout en 2019
qu'on me dit c'est totalement
décomplexée comme quand dame
un ministre n'est cette femme est moche
ce plaisir c'est vraiment voilà c'est
dur oui vous avez de bernard vous avez
besoin de parler dans un stand juste
aghatam ans alors je suis je suis
d'accord avec vous tous pour souligner
l'élégance de brigitte macron dans sa
retenue et tout ça sauf que jusqu où est
ce qu'on peut supporter ça sans réagir
parce que ça on a tous parlé du
président brésilien effectivement qui
s'étale maintenant
et maintenant c'est carrément un
ministre qui se permet d'en rajouter
louis où jésus est valide elle est
carrément moche donc tout gouvernement
brésilien va s'y mettre et nous faudra
surtout rien dire parce que
diplomatiquement c'est pas c'est pas ça
le fait pas de dire quelque chose qu'il
veut elle veut déclarer la guerre au
brésil y'a un moment oui je pense
s'attaque au physique des femmes mais
jamais on ira d'un mec recevra gauche
qui les vieux qui a l'air fatigué qu'il
y en avait qui l'a du bide qui les aura
exemple jamais alors qu'on connaît
organiste et très très longue
par exemple les trains ils ont également
24 ans de différence d'âge mais dans
votre sang c'est à dire que mais damien
et plus jeune 24 ans alors là là on dit
rien il se passe rien en fait c'est son
meilleur ami la baule sonar ou alors il
ya eu un autre truc rappeler de cécile
duflot en 2012 elle était ministre du
logement elle s'est fait siffler à
l'assemblée nationale parce qu'elle
portait une robe
regardez madame cécile duflot ministre
de l'égalité des territoires et du
logement
monsieur le président le goûteux
mesdames et messieurs les députés mais
surtout messieurs visiblement monsieur
le député fromantin
je voudrais vous indiquer que sur ce qui
concerne le grand pas alors voilà donc
sa trace et aussi parfois que l'on
regarde aussi les journalistes les
erreurs que nous faisons parce que
notamment quand on travaille quand on
parle sur les femmes politiques
la plupart des papiers commence toujours
par vêtue d'une élégante aurait mais
alors on peut rien peut rien faire alors
si on le dit plus en plus un costume
gris on le dé plus en plus et pas non
c'est pas vrai c'est un papier qui est
sur une phase politique ont décrit
d'abord sa coupe de cheveux ce à quoi
deux sens ceci est que ce soit quand on
est gay ça mais j'aimerais qu'on
revienne sur jean brigitte macro alors à
nice j'ai perdu parce que je veux dire
c'est que du coup effectivement je me
suis aussi d'une dune ségolène royal qui
à un moment donné quand on lui posait
une question qui lui allait pas dit
c'est parce que tu une femme qu'on peut
être question non c'est parce que c'est
parce que cet homme politique une femme
politique en l'occurrence et que parfois
faut pas s'en servir dans l'autre sens
moi ce qui me gêne sur le côté brigitte
macro effectivement le hashtag miso me
gêne mais également beaucoup aussi
mettre tous les hommes qu'on associe à
ce monsieur qui étaient des propos
orduriers et moi ce qui m'a choqué dans
cette affaire c'est que devant à quel
point le peuple français c'est assez peu
soulevé contre cette affaire avec de
voir que finalement on en parle un peu
mais je le vois aucun français dans la
rue broca aucun partisan mais non
seulement plus s'en tape le président
brésilien est coutumier du fait et c'est
vrai que voilà lui c'est vous trouvez
pas que la fraude les français défendent
pas tellement leur première dame quand
même on n'a pas été tellement tendu qui
se sont mobilisés condamné au brésil
c'est que les volets pour un non on
n'est pas descendu pour défendre garde à
vous voulez que j'envoie sacha au brésil
si vous avez registre il n'a pas attendu
cet épisode malheureux pour savoir comme
le sonar aura bien sûr aux fachos race
maemo phone est un succès attention
comme en danger en mai xinhua la raison
à la raison face à olic des vérités les
récidivistes race donc c'est une honte
pour son peuple
évidemment en revanche moi je suis
d'accord avec jean miché d'accord avec
lisa attention arrêtons de séparer les
hommes et les femmes lance t'emporte en
fait on est en train de castres et les
hommes et on ne solutionnera pas ce
problème là contre les hommes ont
soumissionné à ce problème avec les
hommes côte-à-côte main dans la main
pendant les stigmatisant et pas en les
montrant du doigt réseau là là mais quel
horreur voilà et on n'est pas des
victimes on peut se défendre aussi très
bien entraîné bernard là dessus il ya
parfois je vais faire le des briques des
taux relevés mais qu'ils soient première
dame ou une simple citoyenne ya toujours
un combat à mener pour les femmes
pourraient arriver à l'égalité pour
arriver à les traiter normalement c'est
ça qui est scandaleux dans cette affaire
est ce que vous savez ce qu'est ce qui
est ce qu'elle va faire briller et elle
répondra donc j'attends répondra pas
parce qu'elle est au dessus vous rien
vous cacher je l'eus cet après-midi
évidemment avant de préparer l'émission
que disaient d'accord qu'on peut éviter
des formes et les peintures et alors
elle ne répondra pas évidemment elle
veut elle me dit même diplomatiquement
je ne peux pas répondre je n'ai pas eu à
les faire de ce qu'a fait sa fille
répond dépensé bas vous auriez été fière
elle n'a fait aucun commentaire sur ce
la corse et filles très bien c'est la
forme mais moi c'est moi c'est vrai
c'est moi si c'est bien dit ça de ma
mère pour le brésil non plus à déplorer
si c'est pas un métier
alors moi je suis pas brésiliens n'ont
plus à l'oubli franchement je suis une
dernière chose parce qu'il ya un diktat
de la jeunesse quand même dans la
société sur le cadre de la jeunesse est
d'accord et vous unir diktat de la démo
ça et je remets vous remercier cyril
parce que nous à tpm et autour de la
table valérie isa et moi on a plus de 45
ans non là
[Applaudissements]
bonne humeur simple alors oui eh ben
c'est bien parce que dans les médias on
n'aime pas les les femmes depuis 45 ans
également
non mais c'est vrai qu'ici je voudrais
dire les âges vont de 28 à plus infinie
l'infini non mais c'est vrai c'est comme
dans un problème de matin